.
THE THEORIES RANGE FROM
RIDICULOUS AND LAUGHABLE TO DOWN
RIGHT DANGEROUS.
CNN'S DANIEL DALE JOINS ME NOW
TO TALK ABOUT THIS.
TRUMP IS SAYING ALL THE FBI AND
THE DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE HAS TO
DO IS ASK FOR THESE DOCUMENTS
BACK, AND THERE WOULD HAVE BEEN
NO PROBLEM AT ALL.
ALL THEY HAD TO DO WAS ASK, AND
THAT POST ON HIS TRUTH SITE.
DOES THAT ALIGN WITH WHAT WE
KNOW?
>> IT DOES NOT AT ALL ALIGN WITH
WHAT WE KNOW, JIM.
WE KNOW THERE WAS AN EFFORT OVER
MANY MONTHS, NOT ONLY BY THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE BUT PART
OF THAT BY FEDERAL RECORDS
AUTHORITIES TO GET THESE
DOCUMENTS BACK.
WE KNOW THAT BEFORE THE SEARCH
WARRANT THERE WAS A GRAND JURY
SUBPOENA SEEKING DOCUMENTS AND
OUR CNN COLLEAGUES ARE REPORTING
TODAY THAT IN JUNE, A TRUMP
LAWYER SIGNED A LETTER ASSERTING
THAT THERE WAS NO MORE
CLASSIFIED INFORMATION IN THE
MATERIALS AT MAR-A-LAGO.
PEOPLE AROUND TRUMP ARE ALSO
CLAIMING HE JUST DECLASSIFIED IT
ALL.
BUT THIS IDEA THAT, YOU KNOW,
THEY JUST HAD TO ASK POLITELY
AND THEY WOULD HAVE GOTTEN IT
BACK DOES NOT SQUARE WITH THE
KNOWN TIME LINE.
>> RIGHT.
ANOTHER FALSEHOOD THAT'S BEING
SPREAD IS THAT THE FBI PLANTED
EVIDENCE.
TRUMP POSTED ON HIS SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM, PLANTING INFORMATION
ANYONE, THAT IN QUOTES.
AND YOU FOUND THAT NARRATIVE IS
GAINING TRACTION AMONG SOME
TRUMP ALLIES.
LET'S LISTEN TO THIS.
>> WE KNOW THEY DOCTOR EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THEY PLANT EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THEY HIDE EVIDENCE.
WE KNOW THEY LIE.
WE KNOW THEY LEAK.
>> FOR EXAMPLE, DO I KNOW THAT
THE BOXES OF MATERIAL THEY TOOK
FROM MAR-A-LAGO THAT THEY WON'T
PUT THINGS IN THOSE BOXES TO
ENTRAP HIM.
HOW DO WE KNOW THEY'RE GOING TO
BE HONEST ABOUT WHAT'S IN THE
BOXES.
HOW DO WE KNOW THAT WAS IN THE
BOX BEFORE IT LEFT THE RESIDENCE
IF THE LAWYERS WEREN'T ALLOWED
TO SEE EVERYTHING.
>> SOME WERE SAYING IN TRUMP
WORLD, YOU KNOW, THE DOCUMENTS
WERE DECLASSIFIED, YOU KNOW,
THERE'S NO PROBLEM, THEY'RE
DECLASSIFIED.
AND YOU HAVE OTHERS SAYING THEY
WERE PLANTED.
WERE THEY DECLASSIFIED BEFORE
THEY WERE PLANTED?
IT SOUND AS THOUGH THEY HAVE A
STRATEGY OF JUST THROWING THE
KETCHUP AGAINST THE WALL AND SEE
WHAT STICKS.
>> THAT'S WHAT I WROTE IN MY
PIECE FOR CNN, THEY'RE THROWING
EVERYTHING AGAINST THE WALL.
SOME GROUP OF AMERICANS MIGHT
BELIEVE ONE DEFENSE AND ANOTHER
A TOTALLY CONTRADICTORY DEFENSE.
THERE'S NO BASIS FOR ANY OF
THIS, THIS IDEA OF PLANTED
EVIDENCE HAS BEEN CONJURED OUT
OF THIN AREA.
IT SEEMS LIKE ONE OF THE FIVE OR
SIX OR SEVEN OR EIGHT THINGS
THEY'RE GOING WITH RIGHT NOW!
>> THERE'S ALSO A LOT OF WHAT
ABOUTISM, MAKING A COME BACK NOW
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT DONALD
TRUMP, AND TRUMP AND HIS ALLIES
ARE USING THIS WITH RESPECT TO
FORMER PRESIDENT BARACK OBAMA.
WHAT ARE NEIGH GOING TO DO WITH
THE 33 MILLION PAGES OF
DOCUMENTS THAT PRESIDENT OBAMA
TOOK TO CHICAGO.
AND DANIEL, YOU DID US A SERVICE
HERE, AS YOU ALWAYS DO, FACT
CHECKING THIS.
YOU DUG INTO THIS CLAIM, WHAT
DID YOU FIND OUT?
>> THIS WAS AN EASY ONE TO FACT
CHECK BECAUSE THE NATIONAL
ARCHIVES PUT OUT A DEBUNKING
MAKING SURE THAT THIS CLAIM FROM
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS TOTALLY
UNTRUE.
WHAT THEY SAID IN THE STATEMENT
IS THAT THE NATIONAL ARCHIVES
MAINTAINS EXCLUSIVE LEGAL AND
PHYSICAL CUSTODY OF ALL OF THE
OBAMA PRESIDENTIAL RECORDS.
IT MADE CLEAR THAT IT IS THE
ONE, NOT OBAMA, THAT TOOK 30
MILLION RECORDS TO THE CHICAGO
AREA TO ITS OWN FACILITY, NOT TO
LIKE BARACK OBAMA'S HOUSE.
IT ALSO MADE CLEAR THESE WERE
UNCLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS AND IT
SENT THE CLASSIFIED DOCUMENTS TO
A SEPARATE GOVERNMENT FACILITY
IN THE WASHINGTON, D.C. AR